good morning Millennials welcome back to
the toast happy Monday uh sigh gasp eek
it's all right it's all right you want
to know why why turdy Lou because we are
on our way
to Friday at least we you know gotten
the ball rolling we're on our way just
like Mason Ramsey taught us yeah no it's
a great Monday I'm happy to be back with
my girl Claudia we didn't really catch
up that much this weekend so we kind of
like want to know what's going on with
you how's turdy what's new with turdy
house Theo Theo's doing well
um turdy's okay
what's wrong turdy well turdy you know
had an incident oh goodness me
turdy you know has been talking a lot
about how she wants to try Physical
Therapy she went
I went on Friday after the show and I so
wish I went on Thursday just so I could
have told the story on the podcast on
Friday when it was fresh but quite
possibly the most humiliating thing
happened to me at Physical Therapy like
I haven't recovered since Friday I don't
know how you could please tell them
turdy what happened to you well it just
started out where like the physical
therapist was like a really handsome guy
which I just feel like is wrong
um
like I don't like it's just it's it's a
power imbalance you know he was so
handsome and it just I felt
uncomfortable to be honest and the most
embarrassing thing so I get there and
I'm like so excited because like I
really and he was able to he asked me
like a bunch of questions first sat me
down and he was really able to diagnose
me I think I have a slipped disc and
it's something that like stretches and
you know weekly sessions for a few weeks
really should be able it's very common
so it had nothing to do with my boobs I
thought like he was like no your boobs
will really give you like upper back
pain and I have like lower to middle
back pain
um so I felt good I was getting
diagnosed and then he was like all right
put the gown on
and we'll do some stretches and like
this machine I was like I was so excited
and he said I was like Wow gown I wasn't
expecting that he was like just leave
your bra on
I was like damn okay
and I was thinking I'm like there's no
way he didn't also want me to leave my
undies on like I'm not gonna be bare
vagina
on this table like this is physical
therapy not like a spa even still at the
spot I keep my undies on but like not
everyone does you know it is optional
it's optional I was just like he
definitely meant like just leave your
undergarments on not just my bra yeah he
just probably doesn't know how like
women's stings work yeah yeah so I was
like you know what I'm gonna do
something crazy I'm gonna leave my
undies on because
there's no way there's no way should I
come back he comes back in the room and
I'm in my gown with my bra and undies
and he's like oh oh I'm sorry you could
have left your pants on
[Laughter]
but you said just my bra and I guess he
meant like we're doing my back so like
why would my bottoms be even and I
should have like thought that way but I
was just listening like I was following
the rules and I was like oh I could have
left my pants on thank God I didn't take
my underwear off
and he was like do you want me to leave
so you can put your pants back on I was
like please like thank you and the the
session went on without a hitch but like
my my dignity was just destroyed
stripped from you much like your pants
and he did a really good job of not
making me feel weird but like I'm so
like I'm already like a self-aware
person
um and this was just like on my first
time meeting and honestly it was it was
humiliating
yeah
I can't even offer you words of support
that's like an unburdened yourself that
like I'm doing here on this Monday that
we just kind of have to sit with I know
and there's no awning this burden
um I can't even make you feel better
because it's
such a crazy story stop no I know it's
so bad
like it was humiliating
um and I really I really did try to not
let it like Mar my whole experience is
that the right word Mar yeah
because it was so fabulous you know I
got a diagnosis which made me feel so
good I got a sickening massage and I got
stretches and I've been doing them at
home every day I have to do them today
I've been really good like I am
committed to fixing my back problem and
it was such a it was a gorgeous place
and it was a wonderful experience but I
am blinded by you could leave your pants
on I felt like a predator like yeah
you're like Pee-wee Herman at the movies
yeah it's like
put your pants on oh my God it was it
was humiliating
it was it was horrible and he really he
really was such a nice guy and he didn't
make me feel bad and then he was like I
hope you like country music because
that's what we play and I was like I was
like this this is such a great
experience I wish I didn't ruin it yeah
but it's okay we're gonna get through it
this is part of life it's just important
for everyone to know like before you
judge me like this is my first time ever
doing physical therapy I was shocked to
even see a gown yeah you've only ever
put a gown on like at the doctor where
it's a full body thing like when you see
a gown you take your clothes off right
because like I really I could have just
laid there in my bra and pants no
bra and pants
like I don't know if I needed a gown
whatever it was just you know but he's
like that's how private he was no that's
how courteous this man was such a
gentleman and instead we had courteous
taking her pants off yeah I'm I am going
back tomorrow and I do think I'm gonna
say sir
you are far too handsome to be my
physical therapist give me the ugliest
guy you got no because he there won't be
anyone who can work with you and you're
stuck with a guy who you took your pants
off for and now you're calling him far
too handsome I know I'm afraid Predator
strikes again I feel I'm afraid he's
gonna hear this
um no I I think I need to go with a lady
okay
but you know what like me and me and
this guy like we made really great
progress like I am gonna stick with it
and you know what I've already on the
first day embarrassed myself to the nth
degree like yeah history I think it's
fine it's fine just stop like talking
about people's looks and stop taking
your clothes off unless expressly so you
want me to stop being me no be taking
your clothes off is not a part of no it
was so under the way but I was really I
was like you know what I've never done
physical therapy this is how they do it
I'm gonna dive in and really give it my
all I gave a little too much of my all
and I was wearing these like ugly and
like it was just it was bad
do you see your underwear
yes
full coverage
I mean do you know me it was a little
too full coverage it was like a blanket
that's good that's good yeah they were
like high-waisted black granny panties
you didn't Moon him
I didn't Moon him oh no imagine if I was
wearing like a g-string like hey boys
yeah so that happened to me on Friday
and like my whole weekend was just kind
of a blur of humiliation
I couldn't stop thinking about it Ben
was out of town though so I really
needed to busy myself because if I had
just like stewed on that and been alone
it would have been horrible so I made
myself busy I saw my friends I had a
nice weekend you know went out on Friday
on Saturday night she's a social girl
she has she makes social calls what did
you do
I went out to dinner yeah I went to
Carbone your favorite on Friday
dinner you know
um and then I went out on Saturday to
Boom Boom Room which I haven't been to
In Forever just you know saw the sights
and I got home late oh I fell
I fell but you know what it wasn't like
an embarrassing fall you know the fall
is really what started our entire
unburdened yourself segment I fell in
front of Mary Kate and Ashley oh
actually I don't know which one it was
it was just one I think Mary Kate uh so
if you have been here for a while you
know that that's what started you know
the Monday unburdening segment
um and I fell again on
Saturday night but it wasn't humiliating
because I was with Taylor and Taylor and
like I can't embarrass myself in front
of them like their family like I wasn't
embarrassed in the slightest and this
stranger on the street helped me up and
he was actually really nice and I wasn't
humiliated like I can't explain it there
was nothing about like I genuinely fell
it wasn't like I was so drunk like I
tripped I was wearing big shoes like
things happen I fell I'm a human shoot
me for sure and I'm not worried about
you being humiliated or anything like
I'm worried about your health if you
keep falling like you're gonna hurt
yourself I know but like do you see the
shoes I wear I wear the biggest tallest
platforms and I'm this tiny little girl
who like has no upper body strength I
have no strength anywhere like that's
why you're doing physical therapy right
balance out for your heels a hundred
percent but like I have no core so I
don't have like that the core is what
keeps you centered yeah my core is jelly
yeah
so it's no wonder I'm tripping all over
this town
be careful attorney Lou I know and I did
like I hit the deck like I went like
hands Knees Down on the concrete but I
didn't hurt myself or my ego like I
can't explain how some Falls are just
different no I understand I'm not
embarrassed for you I'm just like now
like you're falling a lot yeah no I have
no center of gravity
I love to have cocktails and I wear big
shoes I think that's a recipe for
disaster agreed and so far you've been
blessed that you haven't you know
hobbled into the toes on crutches on a
Monday morning no on a Monday morning
I'm gonna come in with a boot it's in my
future I know it I'm so reckless I don't
like look before I cross the street
there's curbs and we're in the city
bumpity bumpity and I was in the West
Village those roads haven't been paved
since the early 20s yeah so I'm merely a
victim of circumstance honestly
um
it's a lot of things
yeah including your own choices
he says you're such a teacher sometimes
like I don't think teachers go that hard
no they should the kids they should but
like that's only for the parents to do
yeah no you're such a parent I was
actually thinking this morning while I
was listening to Luke combs's new album
which I'm obsessed Beyond which is
called getting older right yeah
and it's like a part of this dual album
really growing up is the first part and
this is getting older there's a song
growing up and getting older and for me
like growing up was such
an album that really spoke to me and I
realized like of these two albums like I
am growing up and you are getting older
because there's a lot of songs about
like Parenthood yes um and for for the
first part of it feels like Luke wrote
the song when he was like thinking about
having kids the first album and then the
second album was like once he had the
kids you know yeah no I really really
relate to this album there's a couple
songs that just speak right to my heart
it's such a good album his last album
was so good too and like so good I still
wasn't done listening to it but for me
I'm loving this I was listening to it
all week and I actually think I'm gonna
get in the car today and just sit in the
driveway and listen to it some more do
you think that you agree with my call
that like we are the two sides of this
album yes I do like Luke probably like
wrote it when you were I posted that
song take me with you take you with me
to my story because it was like my
favorite and most emotional song and
then you were like oh my God yeah made
me cry not to put you on the spot I did
and then I was thinking like I'm not
ashamed of my emotions I was like oh
what part of this made turdy Luke cry
because I'm like I know why I'm crying
because we're taking rolled everywhere
okay it was for rolled okay because I
didn't know if I was like is she
relating to it like as the kid part of
it is like you know no I actually didn't
relate to that part like when I was a
kid I didn't really want to go places
with my parents I was like let me go
[__] like let me be on my own I'm an
adult yeah yeah you know yeah I don't
really like I relate to the parent part
of that song where it's like I just want
to take you with me everywhere that's us
like we're always thinking like how can
we take Harry with us yeah we're not
doing anything if we can't take him no
yeah like Harry like whatever we plan
something like Harry coming like first
of all increases the budget you know
it increases like the time it increases
everything like yeah but we're all
constantly like how can we accommodate
yeah like or but it's just like how
could we be somewhere without him like
why would I be there is it worth it
no no no
so I'm loving this album It's a
masterpiece and I also listened a lot to
Morgan wallen's new album we have a lot
of new music and we have a new music
story Kelly Clarkson so we're just kind
of it's that time of year where
everyone's gearing up for summer so like
the releases are starting because like
everybody wants to have like the song or
the album of the summer
um and that takes a while so this is
summer summer camera
Center
um so it's that time of year where we're
getting really good music and we're just
I'm loving it yeah me too I'm a little
overwhelmed but now that I have a car I
have a wonderful vessel in which to
listen to all this new music so I'm
feeling less welmed less well that's
good I'm glad the Tesla is underwhelming
you yeah no it's been good Tesla makes
it so easy to listen on Spotify except I
didn't realize I have to pay for a
premium subscription to my Tesla it's
like ten dollars a month if I want
Spotify right there on my screen in
addition to other nuts not just for
Spotify it's like a million things
karaoke you know there's car karaoke in
the Tesla okay that does sound like
something that should be like an
additional bonus but Spotify is like a
basic human right I know well I can
listen you can listen to the radio you
could try Sears could you plug in like
your phone and then for free there's
like no plugs I I don't know how to plug
in my phone this car's turn I also have
not been to Florida to see your Tesla I
am coming this week oh PSA I'm coming to
Florida Thursday
um there is no show Friday Jackie and I
have like a business woman
so there's no show Friday apologies and
then I haven't made my plans yet but I
hope to still be in Florida by Monday so
we could just do the show together
together harmoniously
uh I'm feeling like it might be
acrimoniously why do you feel such a way
turdy Lou I don't know I'm just feeling
like that might be the the vibe sounds
like you want it to be the vibe yeah I
mean a little drama a little fight never
hurt nobody I mean people are interested
I wanted to share this now that enough
time has passed people are always asking
like how do you and Jackie do the show
like if you're like sisters and you're
fighting like what is what happens to
the show and we really like don't fight
as sisters or as business partners but
like what was it last week maybe two
weeks ago during the show like Jackie
and I like maybe like we just like woke
up on the wrong side of the bed we were
we were just like talking about a story
it was like the law roach story we just
like started fighting in the story yeah
no it was like neither of us would back
down from the point from the point and
that we couldn't pivot out of it no and
like I I definitely ended up being wrong
but like you would not let it go I
didn't realize I was being that way like
so we fought literally it was intention
versus impact impact of course what I
was saying I didn't realize I was like
harming you you were just like like dog
with a bone that's what I had said
during the fight and so we literally
fought on the show we cut it out
obviously and then we continue to do the
show and like for the first maybe minute
it was weird only if you knew like maybe
you would even notice it
um but then by the time the show was
over like we ended up with such a great
show it was so funny it really healed us
we didn't even really talk about it we
were both like sorry move on so that's
the only like honestly memory I can
think of in the last maybe three years
where people have asked like what if you
and Jackie fight and I don't have a
point of reference now I do yeah we just
got like stuck in the mud on that
that's exactly what it was we were just
like digging on this stupid [__]
story
we got stuck we got stuck it happened to
the best creatives but then the toast
healed us as the toast does Because by
the end of the show I mean I think I
speak for both of us like I didn't even
care anymore like it was like whatever
the show that was over the show was
great yeah
yeah and it was like it wasn't a fight
worth continuing it's not like either
one of us felt so hurt we needed to talk
about it no no
no and now we can talk about it and now
we've said it and now we have so that's
a little host fun fact for you hello BTS
yeah it was an acrimonious day
twas that turned Harmony harmonious
because the toast is a harmonizing brand
just like me when I listen to Luke Combs
not true but sure charity just wait till
you're in the car with me like I'm
hitting these notes Lucas crying Jackie
is singing Because Luke Combs has a low
voice and you have a high voice Jackie
is singing the same note but in a higher
octave and she thinks that is a Harmony
I'm not getting into this again like
no like we were driving all weekend
listening to Luke Combs and like I was
in the I actually drove a lot this
weekend considering Zach was in the car
with me there was only one outing where
he drove and like your girl was just
like hitting these notes harmonizing let
me let me ask you a question when you
and Zach are going out somewhere
together do you take your mom car you
know your Harry safe Kia or do you take
your Tesla so they're both mom cars
really and yeah like one of them is an
SUV no no they both are they're the same
size so it's like we kind of need to
switch one of them which is again you
need to get like a convertible or a one
car that's really big because kind of
both of ours are like if we have guests
or something it's a little small for a
mid-size yeah so does your back row of
Tesla have captain seats or three seats
three so that's and then is there a back
back row no okay but Zacks has captain
seats and a backpack rows right they're
both kind of can see the same amount of
people just depends on the vibe no that
other car Zach's car is like the mom's
SUV not the way Zack Zack is that's his
mobile office he's got literally like
desktop computers in there you know he
has a folding table in there he has a
fridge he's literally he can live out of
the car yeah no you'll first of all I
think you have the wrong impression of
Tesla that I do uh car if when we were
in Lauren Elizabeth's Tesla in La is it
the same one I don't remember what kind
she had okay I have to see it and I
can't wait to drive it I know you have
to see it I'm excited for you to drive
it but most of the time when we in the
last few weeks like when we're doing a
family outing we take the tester just
because it's more fun but Zach will
drive it sometimes too but yesterday we
took the Kia we needed the extra seat
um just depends really got it yeah Bryce
is comfortable in both vehicles he made
himself at home low-key like having a
baby he's like low-key annoying with the
car it's like that car seat is [__]
huge yeah and then in what nobody wants
to sit in the middle seat next to the
car seat the car seat's like on your lap
for sure but you get to like play with
it the whole time of course of course
but then there's also like the car seat
um
what's it called the in if you if it's
your permanent car you install like a
car seat base and that way the car seat
just clicks in it's great but that but
then that makes that seat unusable even
when there's nothing yeah yeah for sure
like oh look at these kids my God they
should just need to learn how to drive
already no no get their own cars that's
my job
oh that's true you did just learn how to
drive yeah so it's been a fun adventure
um that's great and you know what else
is great the wealth of Stories We have I
mean after the show on Friday you know
Reese Witherspoon strategic Queen
dropping in on Friday afternoon like
divorce then there was Selena's new man
like actually a lot came out we have a
lot to discuss we do
and I'm ready we should we could yeah we
will I think we will yeah the fast five
stories that you need to know
and today's episode is brought to you by
Jacqueline's favorite brand Babble one
of the most exciting things about the
new year is that you have no idea what
Adventures are in store for you from new
travel experiences to new jobs or
picking up new skills there's no better
way to prepare for 2023 than by learning
a new language with Babel Babel is the
language learning app that sold more
than 10 million subscriptions and thanks
to Babel's addictively fun and easy
bite-sized language lessons you can feel
confident no matter where the New Year
takes you
so I think a great reason to learn a new
language is if you have a trip coming up
because really you really don't need
that reason but like it's the impetus to
get you started but learning a new
language is such a great way to like
train your brain as an adult like pick
up a new hobby and babble makes it so
easy with Babel you only need 10 minutes
to complete a lesson so you can start
having real life conversations in a new
language in as little as three weeks
other language learning apps use AI for
their lessons but Baba lessons were
created by over 150 language experts and
voiced by real native speakers not
computers their teaching method has been
scientifically proven to be effective
and they end they have 14 different
languages that you can choose from plus
Babel speech recognition technology
helps you improve your pronunciation and
accent so not everyone they're not going
to know you're a tourists you're going
to be so authentic they're gonna be like
oh where are you from America
there are so many ways to learn with
Babel in addition to the lessons you can
add access podcasts Games videos stories
and even live classes right now get up
to 55 off your subscription when you go
to babel.com toast it comes with a
20-day money-back guarantee that's Babel
babel.com toast for up to 55 off your
subscription Babble language for Life
today's episode is also brought to you
by Perfect bar
looking for a protein bar that actually
tastes good well look no further than
perfect bar with their lineup of fresh
from the fridge protein bars perfect bar
is exactly what you've been looking for
no chalky artificial aftertaste here
made with freshly ground nut butter
organic honey and 20 organic superfoods
perfect bar has a variety of products
like protein bars little snack size bars
that are also good and good for you
you're sure to find something you love
my favorite is the dark chocolate chip
peanut butter because why perfect bar is
so fabulous is that they're kept in the
fridge because they're made with real
real ingredients so that means when you
pull it out of the out of the fridge
that dark chocolate is going to be nice
and crunchy it's going to be a little
hard then the inside is like a doughy
texture it's a real nice and they add
you know a little sea salt you know a
little little taste it's nice
they also um have a new snack size that
is packed with six grams of protein and
150 calories so a little goes a long way
throw it in your purse at the beginning
of the day midday pickup you know late
lunch crash throw that perfect bar in
your mouth you'll be set they're made
with whole food ingredients that means
no artificial preservatives and that's
why they're stored in the fridge so grab
one after a workout or for a quick bite
while you're out shopping and feel good
about what you're snacking about if you
aren't convinced already they're also
non-GMO project verified gluten-free soy
free low GI and kosher to all of our
Jewish Queens perfect bar knows that
it'll be Love At First Bite so for a
limited time they're offering you a
chance to try their refrigerated protein
bars for free so sign up for email or
text upload a picture of your receipt
from your local grocery store and they
will reimburse you for the cost of one
bar directly into your venmo or PayPal
account all you have to do is go to
perfect snacks.com toast to get a free
perfect bar today that's perfect
snacks.com toast to get a free perfect
bar today happy snacking
thank you Claudia you're welcome our
first story the story that's on
everybody's lips
is that Harry Styles and I'm rata we're
on each other's lips this weekend they
were spotted making out in Tokyo hot and
heavy and
everyone is really really shook about it
so he's in Tokyo for his love on tour
tour he was doing he's all over Asia
he's everywhere who knows what brings
her there if she just happened to be
there too it looked like they were at
some sort of small gathering of friends
yes
um and it looks like someone else at the
party was the one who took the video
like this is not Paparazzi yeah it was
definitely boots on the ground it was
boots on the ground and it was you know
it was a passionate make out
yeah we are now getting all different
angles videos photos they were
definitely making out there's no you
know way around that it was definitely
them and they were definitely making out
and people are shook I mean I think
whatever Harry is tied to a new person
people are automatically gonna hate it
because so many of his fans feel so
territorial and everybody feels like it
should be them and I totally relate to
that sentiment
um here are my thoughts I thought she
was dating that guy Eric Andre because
literally a month ago on Valentine's Day
they were naked on Instagram together so
I'm just confused about that
um two you know one thing about me is
ah
how do I put this delicately
I'm not like an M Rod a super fan I feel
like every time we talk about her every
time we talk about her like I say that
like I feel like her brand which is very
like sexy feminist is so like not my
vibe whatsoever so I acknowledge that
I'm definitely biased so therefore I'm
not here for this pairing
um I also feel like it's a little soon
you know Harry just got out of a really
long term like it was a long
relationship that Olivia thing like it's
a little soon
yeah I mean a little soon for a makeout
no yeah
so
I am not that's not who I would choose
for him knowing that he is you know like
the second most eligible bachelor after
Jason Sudeikis oh sudakis
uh but I kind of ship I think like
they're so both eligible they're so good
looking they're so single why not
they're pretty similar in age you know
it's definitely a more age-appropriate
relationship than the last time and this
one is like a little bit more obvious
with Olivia Wilde I think we were all
like what but I also don't think that
they're gonna start dating I think maybe
the fact that these videos went viral
will make them like go out again but
they were just making out like I don't
think they're together emperada has been
like bopping around dating she's single
she's with Eric Andre
she was rumored to be with Brad Pitt
like I think she's just seeing what's
out there and
fortunately for us this was caught on
camera but we were never meant to know
about this very true as well even though
it does make me feel like it's a little
more serious if she's in Tokyo like why
would she be there if not for him it's
not like she's filming a big movie in
Tokyo you know I feel like celebrities
to like fly someone out to your show to
the hookup is like for sure
Tokyo no I know it's not you know North
Carolina it's Tokyo that's what like a
19-hour flight yes that's not a flying
out just to see that's not no maybe she
was in a neighboring country and they
lived up
she's literally Shawn Mendes I'm a
couple of hundred miles from Japan I was
just thinking what's that song There's a
song about this it's like lost in Japan
tonight I just said that a couple of
hundred miles from Japan Japan and I
that could be what happened that's very
true
I don't know for me
and I feel like I say this every time
like it's always like who Pete Davidson
gonna date next and we were like you
know guessing and then it was emrata
it's so obvious like I don't know I like
when it's obvious though sometimes I
don't know I just wish Harry would like
it surprise me you know date someone
ugly date someone chubby okay but he was
couldn't have been more surprising with
Olivia Wilde and you weren't happy about
that yeah maybe I'm just like a woman
hater that's kind of what I'm feeling no
I feel like you're feeling the way a lot
of fans are feeling which is like it's
never going to be good enough unless
it's you like the way you just said like
someone
chubby yeah
someone who's a podcaster like I feel
like unless it's you
yeah you're not gonna be happy
no that's but like let me really say
like with my full body how like I'm
really not interested not that anyone's
asking I'm like not interested in dating
Harry Styles like first of all like I am
happily married lest we forget yeah
right right Germaine to the con but I'm
not available like I'm really not
available
Kendall like I think they're perfect for
each other like I don't think I would be
feeling that way this way if if Kendall
was the girl in Tokyo
yeah they are literally so similar I
know which is why it's just like this
block that you have you know I'm not
saying anything I say like makes sense
no no because really on its face like
these are
two very
suited people who are suspended for one
another it's also just so crazy to think
how like Emily Ratajkowski for most like
the entirety of her Fame has been tied
down you know she's been married for so
long and so imagine if she wasn't like
how many you know eligible men she could
have dated like that's commitment I
think she's making up for lost time yes
she definitely is
do you blame her I just want to go on
the record that I am here for this
couple I don't think it'll turn serious
but if it were to like I kind of love
that like photos of them being styling
and walking in the streets like wait by
the way I totally forgot before the show
we were talking about stories
um do we have a story about Gwyneth
Paltrow's trial no we don't I know she's
going viral though she is like let's
just talk about it for two seconds
because I have so many thoughts
you don't have to add it as a story just
like a separate anecdote
obviously this clip went viral of the
opposing Council asking her about Taylor
Swift because Taylor Swift really kind
of invented the whole thing of counter
suing for a dollar where it's like
you're making a point it's not about
money it's about Justice and
then she was asked do you know Taylor
Swift are you friends with Taylor Swift
it was so irrelevant and it really I
know we're all like joking about this
it's such a gross misuse of our justice
system it's an abuse of people's time
this whole thing is a circus it's a
farce and like everyone is sitting there
like everyone online is like you know
Gwyneth Paltrow because she's been
sitting there getting cross-examined
like with a smile on her face because
this is so stupid she didn't do anything
wrong and everyone's like knock when
it's Paltrow being so patronizing really
I would be too like this whole
trial is a farce it's a circus and like
yeah it's funny in the pop culture haha
like at the end of the day like this is
a
an abuse of the judicial system it's
abusive the judge's time the jury's time
like this is so stupid it's not [__]
real literally nothing happened and it's
moronic moronic but I mean how can you
say that with certainty that nothing
happened that she did not do this
because look at what the council is
spending their time on do you know
Taylor Swift
are you friends with Taylor Swift
when was the last time you spoke to
Taylor Swift how did this happen every
day like where people sue for nonsense I
know but we're all like eating it up and
I feel like it's really highlighting
like how this is we're such a what's the
word I'm looking for
with an L
litigious litigious country you know
everyone just sees everything that
happens to them as an opportunity to sue
yeah well that's for sure but I do think
it's part of you know
being an American is having the right to
sue someone if you have been wrong but
also having the right to defend yourself
and like letting it play out if Gwyneth
is being wronged in this situation like
the justice system will prevail in her
favor and for this guy like if he really
was attacked by Gwyneth then he'll have
his Justice too like that's really what
the judicial system is for I know it's
like a waste of everyone's time but that
is what like in any case like there's
someone who's blatantly wrong and
blatantly right but we have to sit there
and we have to talk about it yeah I
really hope like nobody's buying what
this you know victim quote
is saying I'm so and yes I'm definitely
biased I love Gwyneth yeah um but like I
don't know how anyone could like watch
this trial and be like yeah like justice
for this guy like well what I'm saying
and his daughter's on the stand like
making jokes like literally auditioning
for SNL like it's moronic yikes what I'm
seeing though no people this quote of
glennis has been going viral because the
prosecutor asked um
like did you suffer at all
I want to get the exact quote like did
you suffer from this incident like I
know you had planned like an expensive
trip in Park City right uh uh what was
the exact question uh she was asked
about the losses that she had suffered
from the crash and Gwen said well we
lost half a day of skiing
so yeah it sucks because it was so
insignificant like
people are like mocking her over her
response though like you know any slight
inconvenience to your life well we lost
half a day of skiing no because that's
how minimal this whole situation was
like nothing happened
you know yeah actually I saw a quote
from Gwyneth that from her point of view
like the man came from behind her he
collided into her and his two skis went
between her skis
so it like uh like her legs spread thank
God she's so flexible I know but she
said she At first she thought it was
like a sexual assault you know what I
mean because if you don't know what's
happening and all of a sudden
something's coming from behind and
forcing your legs apart like that's
pretty scary yeah
I just it's so dumb and she's handling
herself with the utmost Grace because I
can never
but that's you know that's what the
courts are for and yes people take
advantage yeah but it's also for the
courts to you know and still that people
don't take advantage and it could
Gwyneth could have countersued for 300
000 too you know what I mean like no I
mean she's not trying to punish him
she's just trying to clear her name
clear her name it would have been easier
for her because the judge kept it at 300
000 to just pay it and not she's
spending more on legal fees honestly
yeah but your name is your name right
right
so she has to go through this circus
just to clear her name
yes but having the opportunity to clear
your name
is what makes this country great I agree
so you just gotta trust the process
attorney Lou even though I know it can
be harrowing not your favorite thing to
do 100 percent
are you ready for our next okay so
overall let's move on from Harry and
marata overall
it's fine it's not like the most
original creative idea it's fine
at least it's age-appropriate yeah I
think it's a little cute
I'm I'm so not where you are
it's just like you know they're so good
looking what's bad yeah
are you ready for our next story
yes definitely one ship builds another
crumbles Reese Witherspoon another sinks
another sinks Reese Witherspoon and her
ex-husband husband Jim Toth are
divorcing after 12 years of marriage
Reese and her husband are calling it
quits the star announced the difficult
news on her Instagram on Friday she said
we have some personal news to share it
was with a great deal of care and
consideration that we have made the
difficult decision to divorce the
actress detailed that despite their
split they've enjoyed so many wonderful
years together and are moving forward
with deep love kindness a mutual respect
for everything they've created together
their biggest priority is their 10 year
old son Tennessee as well as their
entire family as they navigate this next
chapter that's a nice name yeah you know
why this is tough
because it's a celebrity businessman
Beau relationship that didn't stand the
test of time I mean and and it was a
successful relationship they got married
they were together for 12 years which in
Hollywood is very long so I wouldn't
consider this a failure but it's always
tough to see you know the businessman Bo
celeb Starlet Duo go down agreed though
I don't think that this is a knock in
the business and bow category because
when I think of a business Mambo I want
someone who's out of the industry like
right he's a businessman but he's an
agent he's still in Hollywood and to me
that's it's yes he's in the business of
Hollywood it's better than dating a
fellow actor but still not what I would
have chosen so I don't feel responsible
for this I don't feel responsible either
and I find
I I think you know the proceedings she's
so rich now and they built that company
hello sunshine that was just valued at a
billion dollars they built it during she
built it during the marriage I have to
assume he was a part of it he's a
businessman and they were married
um so I wonder what this means yeah but
it's not like when they got married she
was like some nobody nobody with no
success like I'm sure everything is
extremely tied up and spelled out
yeah one of my favorite things about
Reese Witherspoon is the way she's just
kind of navigated uh maintaining her
status as America's sweetheart and
nobody seems to remember that video when
she got pulled over I think she was
drunk driving and she was like screaming
at the cop like do you know who I am I'm
America's sweetheart that's one of my
favorite moments in pop culture history
and I love that nobody talks about it
because she's a queen and she's totally
about to pass it
um and she like built this sickening
business and she really is like with her
it's like the cream Rises she's so
talented you know a million star let's
try to Star business start businesses
not all of them become billion dollar
companies backed by BlackRock you know
yeah and she's really just done
something so unique like with the books
like she's really well I think she kills
it I think it followed a really natural
progression and that's always how the
best things happen and now so many I
think it's her passion try to emulate
hello sunshine but I think when she
started a book club like she just really
liked to read and then she read so many
great books that she was like I'd really
like to see this as a movie and then
she's like hey I'm a movie person why
not me right you know that's how the
best things happen it's when you're
trying so hard to do something
and that's when it's bogus yeah so
she'll still be rich of course I just do
wonder you know celebs they're all
tight-knit you know they get their
prenups postnaps they do all that but
California where a lot of people get
married is a community property state
that means you know half to everyone
yeah
well I hope that they can settle things
nicely harmoniously and not
acrimoniously no no
um and also you know she's now on the
market
enter to our list like who do we see
Reese Witherspoon with I mean part of me
you know always will stand her and Ryan
Phillippe I think you know that was just
it was a moment in time but they have
two children together you know they're
both so good looking would it hurt to
try again I don't know I don't know but
I don't get good vibes from the two of
them
I do feel like they were definitely like
young and it was fast and they were you
know hot and heavy until they weren't do
you think she'll go like older or
younger this might be the time in her
life where she goes younger I mean she
literally could have the experience that
she played in Nancy Myers's daughter's
film home again where she dates of 12
year old
um but I don't like that for her now I
think I think Rhys is like really
confident in her in her you know
age and her maturity and I think she'll
want someone who validates that like
someone on her level I really I don't
see her dating someone younger I really
don't but I feel like her being with Jim
was like making that choice you know
like yeah true like she was going into
the business World more like she's
really in a serious relationship like I
think whatever she does next will be
Divergent from that not saying she's
going to go younger but she I don't know
that
that is interesting
you know you always like then just
choose the opposite of what you've had
right just as like a knee-jerk reaction
like it might be with like a backup
dancer after this right very Casper
Smart yeah
no that's a good point it's also just
hard when you're such a powerful woman
a lot a lot of people can't handle that
right but that's why I think a lot of
powerful women for a number of reasons
but one of them being this they go
younger because like young guys they're
not in competition with you like so true
and there's like a graduated college of
power imbalance because of the age
yeah like so it's a little you know
what's a couple billion it's not
competitive whatsoever such a good point
so there it is makes you think and
because they can
right no and it's fun like who no
offense who wants a saggy ball sack when
you can have a fresh one like I get it
I get it yeah isn't that why you go
younger you know perky tits versus saggy
tits perky balls versus saggy balls like
I gotta um a few reasons but yes
Aesthetics yes right like conventionally
saggy balls are not as appetizing as
perky balls thank you thank you for
continuing to say saggy balls who wants
a wrinkly scrotum when you could have a
you know a big fleshy one I get it I'm a
human too I get it
I get it yeah but I think also after 12
years of marriage with a businessman
who's like you know probably smart and
has opinions it's like I don't want you
to challenge me anymore shut the [__] up
yeah no I don't know what I'm beautiful
pretty I just need someone beautiful
yeah yeah so I wouldn't be shocked
either if that's kind of like a rebound
relationship for her just to feel
something different I get it yeah but
you know they were kind of a staple in
the industry so for sure and they were
very like low-key to the point where you
almost forgot you was married yeah but
like then all these articles are coming
out that this was like you know no
surprise to Hollywood insiders they've
been living why haven't they told us
they've been living separate lives for a
while
right everyone loves to be like oh I
knew yeah totally it's everyone's
favorite thing I called it yeah like no
I've literally known this for years
Insider's new like shut up
shut up are you ready for our next story
yes
but it appears as though you're not now
I am got it some new relationship news
potentially oh this is weird Selena
Gomez and Zayn Malik spark romance
rumors after alleged New York City
dinner date
Celine and Zane sparked relationship
rumors after the two singers were
allegedly spotted on what appeared to be
a romantic date night in New York City a
hostess at a celebrity loved Manhattan
Restaurant witnessed Selena and Zayn
locking lips while grabbing dinner
together on Thursday night Clarissa
Garcia claimed in a tick tock video that
has since gone viral
she told Paige Sarah
is definitely also fired come Monday
morning yeah but I feel like I mean now
she's in paychecks her Tick Tock went
viral probably not worth losing your job
but it's worth a shot you know it it
like isn't worth a shot because people
who like make videos like this they are
definitely have a moment it's a flash in
the pan they don't really start careers
on on as digital influencers after this
like yeah it's the one video nobody's oh
let me follow that girl who one time saw
something you know yeah but maybe if she
has something this could have just been
like a little boost and now she has you
know her big thing and we're all gonna
be able to see it I don't know she could
have just send it to dumois but actually
I probably wouldn't have believed it she
said no one noticed them except for the
hostess it was pretty public but no one
really cares about famous people in New
York did they say what restaurant that's
also not true say what restaurant and
that is not true I totally agree not
true they didn't say the restaurant they
blurted out they walked in hand in hand
making out and she seated them
I don't know this is like one girl's
account and she also said like nobody
cared and I'm just telling you if Selena
Gomez is insane Malik walked into a
restaurant no matter how cool it was
people care also like Pixar didn't
happen yeah okay but let's let's play
Let's assume excuses they went to dinner
um making out at face value too sure
let's say they're dating let's just say
I can't help but wonder what this means
for Taylor Swift like that's over my
that's what you were saying please
explain why you're well Taylor Swift's
best friends in this world for many
years these aren't like fake celebrity
friendships like they're real Selena
Gomez and Gigi Hadid Gigi Hadid is
obviously you know very tightly linked
to Zayn Malik they have a child together
um
what does that mean for Taylor Swift you
know but also you know that also means
that Selena has like some inside scoop
from Taylor about Gigi and Zayn and
unless we not forget Zayn like smacked
Yolanda Hadid and threw her down the
stairs with the elder abuse like I can't
imagine hearing that firsthand and then
being like yeah that's someone I want to
date set me up yeah like let me bring my
grand to go meet my new boyfriend so he
could you know give her a give her the
old one too yeah I just I feel like we
don't talk enough about how Zayn Malik
was accused of elder abuse like no no he
was accused and the thing to me is like
shortly there after like him and JC
broke up for good right I have not been
like spotted there's no going back like
that it's true yeah it's true it has to
be yeah
it's not like so and so said like right
Yolanda said there were papers yeah
that's why we know about it yeah and
then like Gigi did not go back like it's
true yeah I'm in agreement
um
so yes not really like what you want to
hear about
a potential boyfriend and I'm sure
Selita has even more details about it
from Taylor yeah I feel like Taylor has
always told the line about a few of her
friendships conflict a little bit yeah
um you know because Gigi's such good
friends with Kendall and she's such good
friends with Taylor and obviously
there's bad blood
oh yeah cringe and um she's done a good
job I feel like even when she hangs out
with Gigi or Selena they don't hang out
together so yeah she'll toe the line
she'll be fine plus she's busy and is
probably paying attention to all of this
and I guess I don't believe it
that I feel is her Saving Grace like she
doesn't have a responsibility to like
you know Gigi or Selena right now
because she has a responsibility to her
millions of fans like she's out here
doing the most three-hour shows you know
twice a week yeah she can't be bothered
she's traveling she's she can't be
bothered to be bogged down with Petty
gossip by the time her tour is over we
won't even remember that this was a
story yeah so true great call and you
don't believe it
not it not at face value no you know I
just need a little bit more than one
person's account no and like maybe they
walked into a restaurant together
um I don't think they were making out I
don't think that they were making out
and nobody cared and nobody took a
picture and nobody saw them
um
again just like with my Chainsmokers
call like I think they might have been
working on something like maybe she's
working on something with a lot of
different people has an album coming out
like they got dinner after studio time
I wanted to tell you
um last week I forget where I was but I
met a toaster who was just delightful
and she was like by the way I was at the
bowling alley next to Drew and Selena
like I was the one who like took those
photos that went viral and they were
making out the whole time
they were they were
and she was like it was like the
craziest thing that ever happened to me
I was like oh my God yes Queen right
place and she didn't have a photo of
them making out she did
and it didn't make it to the Airways I
don't know why it didn't make it to the
airwaves did you see the photo I uh did
not
you have to question everything turdy
Lou no I know but I don't think a
toaster would lie to me like for real no
I don't think so either but like that's
an account I believe you know but I
don't know this girl but now I know the
Selena the the Drew witness I don't know
this Witness
I don't know turdy Lou and Pixar didn't
happen literally you want to know why
you want to know why I feel like these
two situations are different because
when the Drew and Selena thing happened
the person who took the photos didn't
like try to get famous off of it they
just like put the photos out and like
TMZ got them like the whole story being
centered around one woman makes me feel
like
it's very possible this is like a a
stunt or you know like because now we're
all talking about Clarissa or whatever
her name was yeah
that makes me a little suspicious well
Clarissa got he's not the hostess sorry
Clarissa's friend is the hostess and
texted Clarissa so now we're two degrees
it's telephone it's a yeah but and the
text message is from Clarissa go are you
ready for no from Hostess go are you
ready for this I'm screaming Clarissa
what I'm scared what happened
Hostess tell me how Selena Gomez and
Zayn just walked into restaurant that's
blurred out hand in hand making out and
I seated them Clarissa shut the [__] up
hostess girl everyone's out here feeling
bad for Selena meanwhile she's with
Gigi's baby daddy
okay so now I didn't realize that that
is another layer sorry that's confusing
Clarissa don't even work at the
restaurant no
Hostess just said whatever she wanted
and she gets to keep her job right
unless somebody at the restaurant can
make you know the connection between
Clarissa and potential Hostess but they
can't because this didn't happen so
every big restaurant is like we're Gigi
and where's Zayn and Selena here not us
not us every Hostess is safe not
Clarissa sending every VIP Restaurant in
this town into a tizzy yeah but there's
nothing I don't think this is true
interesting okay well I need to wait and
see if the more stuff happens yeah so
I'm gonna need more than Clarissa's text
messages yeah
agreed
before we dive in please allow me the
honor of telling everyone that today's
episode is brought to you by Squarespace
thank you Claudia
from websites and online stores to
marketing tools and analytics
Squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business so whether you're in
e-commerce you want to start a side
business we just want to start a website
check out Squarespace it is the
all-in-one platform to get everything up
and running it is so easy whether you
have experience building websites doing
engineering or not you really don't need
it because Squarespace will do it all
for you so if you're into e-commerce
here are some of the wonderful features
that the websites on Squarespace can
create you can connect your social media
accounts you can get traffic overview
basically see how your visits unique
visitors page views are trending
um video blocks so you can present your
videos from YouTube Vimeo Animoto you
also have content ownership with
Squarespace you own all the content that
you put on the platform because they
offer a one-click data portability
um
whether you want to start a blog or a
podcast or you know food there are so
many different features on Squarespace
that'll help you get your business up
and running really easy
um they have mobile optimized websites
so all their websites are optimized for
mobile so the content automatically
adjusts so your site looks great whether
you're looking at it from a computer or
a phone check out squarespace.com toast
for a free trial and when you're ready
to launch use offer code toast to save
10 off your first purchase of a website
or a domain again that's squarespace.com
toast you'll get the free trial when you
use that link and then once you're ready
to launch use the code toast and you'll
save 10 off your first purchase of a
website or a domain thank you
Squarespace today's episode is also
brought to you by the farmer's dog when
you look at a bag of dog food you'll see
pictures of bright carrots juicy steaks
deliciousness but then you open the bag
all you're getting are burnt smelly
pellets
which is just not not the vibe for the
stress Bros they deserve the best and
dog food needs some fresh thinking
so welcome the farmer's dog it is real
food you can feed your dog the farmer's
dog it is real fresh healthy food with
whole meat vegetables it's gently cooked
in human grade kitchens to preserve all
the nutritional value it's so easy when
you sign out on the website it gets
really personalized you tell them about
your dog and then they'll deliver
personalized vet developed recipes for
as little as two dollars a day it
arrives pre-portioned and ready to serve
packs and it is conveniently delivered
on your schedule dog people all across
the country have ordered millions of
meals from the farmer's dog and it has
never been easier to invest in your
dog's health with fresh food Theo's now
unlike month I think like maybe three or
four of their Farmer's dog his weight is
so stabilized he used to be like chunky
and then a few weeks later like really
small we were not really able to
regulate his weight but it feels way
more stable now he's more energy his
breath is better his coat is really
shiny I just feel like all these little
things I would notice have really been
improved thanks to the farmer's dog so
get 50 off your first box of fresh
healthy food at the farmersdog.com toast
plus you get free shipping when you use
that link just go to the farmersdog.com
toast to get that 50 off the
farmersdog.com toast listen the stress
Bros are the most important people in
your lives like start investing in their
health it is worth it it is
thank you Claudia for that important
message it's a pleasure next story Kelly
Clarkson's divorce album is forthcoming
it will cover The Good the Bad and the
Ugly Kelly announced on Sunday that
she's coming out with a new album called
chemistry the talk show host explained
in an Instagram video that she came up
with the title after her acrimonious
divorce from her ex-husband Brandon
Blackstock I feel like we are so like on
The Cutting Edge and like really have
made the word acrimonious like I have
this revolution yes Renaissance we love
to do that for Words acrimonious wench
nefarious true the list goes on I was TR
I'll start a list on my phone she said I
was trying to find a word that really
described the whole thing because I
didn't want everybody to think I was
just coming out with some just like I'm
angry I'm sad like just one or two
emotions you know this album is
definitely the Arc of an entire
relationship and a whole relationship
shouldn't be just brought down to one
thing
so there's you know The Good the Bad and
the Ugly kind of thing going on in it
she said uh chemistry can be really
amazing sexy cool fun thing but it can
also be very bad for you so she thought
it would be the perfect title for the
all-encompassing record
I mean respectful Queen and this man has
literally you know robbed her blind
tried to strip her of everything and she
still remains like such a peaceful
respectful co-parent even in the music
she's not making a divorce album it's
really probably will be more of like a
tragedy yeah well I think one like he's
the father of her children and so you
just want to be respectful because they
will be hearing this one day but two I
think there's a lot of Truth in the
statement that it's not just like angry
sad bad like it's a whole range of
emotions you know it's grief and it's
loss and it's you know I'm sure some of
it is extremely Bittersweet and even
when you're fighting with someone I know
he like you know squatted in the Montana
house and there was all this drama but
like you loved this person once they
were married for uh 10 years since 2013
yeah so almost 10 years like there's a
lot of history there and I think that it
is reductive to just be angry and that's
not true to The Human Experience no it's
a very mature take and she's a mature
Queen so yeah why would you expect
anything less like she's not putting out
a diss track this album what do we think
like there's obviously going to be like
a lead single called chemistry so what
do we think the song chemistry is going
to be like sound like it's gonna be like
uh you know Kelly's iconic sound but the
lyrics are gonna be kind of country
where they kind of switch up at the end
like all these good things about
chemistry but then it was like the
chemistry that undid them but like give
me a Melody oh
this is really your specialty
YouTube history it's like a hardware you
do the music I'll do the lyrics you're
literally uh Drew Barrymore I am Hugh
Grant 100
.
you don't think
I think it's gonna be upbeat where it
like builds and builds and builds in
like the chorus is like upbeat and fun
and then it ends with like a Zinger line
where it's like yeah
yeah like yeah yeah like we like
yeah I don't even want to go there but I
could hear it in my head what's the song
I made up for Selena how did it go oh my
God I could have better than a fat not
myself
I'm not alone too much to dance with
your heart yeah
[Music]
so good so good so I think it's gonna be
pop Anthem but then it's like a one-two
punch you know what I'm excited about
I feel like our generation and like the
culture has an entirely new respect for
Kelly Clarkson in the last few years I
feel like her brand has like really
taken off with the show and
um her karaoke cover is her karaoke I
feel like there's a whole new audience
of people who are looking forward to
this and so I feel like in the past a
lot of the music she released has gone
under appreciated I really feel that way
and it's disgusting it's disgusting and
I think like that this is going to be
really big for her she's partnering
um not partnering she's pairing this
with her Vegas residency which was right
when kovid started we had tickets
um she had to cancel it obviously and
now they are rescheduled for this summer
yes I saw that too she has a 10-day
Vegas residency in the works so that's
really exciting I don't think I'll be
able to make it um
so I'm just like kind of devastated
about that but I'm hoping that she will
do a chemistry tour yeah and bring it on
down here to me uh but this is her first
traditional album since 2017. like the
fans are ready it's been six years and
I've never pressured Kelly into
releasing new music no because she's
really been killing it in all other
aspects of her career and like honestly
I don't want this album for a few months
because like I've got Luke Combs I've
got Morgan Wallen I've got Mimi Webb
like I'm booked in busy Kelly right now
she said it's coming sooner than y'all
think but she didn't drop a date which
for me feels like it'll be at least May
I need time for sure yeah her also her
titling at chemistry like was giving me
like Ed Sheeran Vibes now that we broke
down another subject in school another
subject in school because we don't know
where he goes from here he's done all
the
math symbols he had said
in an interview recently he was asked he
says he has another you know symbolic
thing you know what he could do he could
do the exponent sign
you know um the little Carrot Top yeah I
don't know what he would call it but
something about like multiple of
um
exponential that's a good title PEMDAS
is better the PEMDAS tour yeah he's on
the he's going on the PEMDAS tour I know
let me just tell you how never once in
my life have I successfully used PEMDAS
in an equation like equation that had
parentheses exponent multiply that [__]
doesn't work like you cannot convince me
that it does no it does
PEMDAS doesn't work it does
it's a faulty equation it's an acronym
for a reason
it's a lie
I think you've just been burned
by PEMDAS definitely
I think you have some trust issues and
you have walls up I definitely I'm like
on an episode of The Bachelor like I
have walls up you know what you have a
you have parentheses up
to your left and to your right
everywhere I look I'm just kind of being
closed in on that's so turdy
that's so dirty it's the PEMDAS she
can't solve
that's so turdy it's the flashlight she
can't see that's so dirty where are her
beans yeah or that's so turdy it's the
flashlight she can see that's so turdy
blame Ben stop for celebrity oh that's
really good how is BSC BSC is doing well
BSC is home the celebrity has returned
thank God and he made it out of the
country they let him back in yeah of
course Ben was able to find someone
somewhere in New York to get his
passport to they were flying to Miami
Ben was flying through Miami to the
Bahamas Ben waited for them in the
airport got his passport and flew out to
the Bahamas that's insane that's Ben's
top for a celebrity yeah I guess people
will really do anything for you when
you're a celebrity
thus he got his passport so was the
lesson learned of course not [__] I know
I'm glad he's home and back with his
turd though me too Theo really missed
him we know you missed him too oh
desperately yeah so hate hate being
alone yeah are you ready for a fifth and
final story which is some more
iconic singing female news yeah oh yeah
Adele has extended her Las Vegas
residency and is planning a concert film
Adele announced Sunday that she's
extending her Las Vegas residency with
34 more dates between June and November
and also plans to release a concert film
Saturday night's show was the last
performance in her original weekends
with Adele series that covered 34 dates
since last November on the Strip her
representative said Adele's show will
resume at the Coliseum Coliseum at
Caesar's Palace on June 16th
and run through November 4th the June
performances will be recorded and
released as a concert special
I mean I don't know why she wouldn't
continue when I was at the show she
literally said I love doing this like I
literally get to be in Vegas for a day
and a half I get to be at home in La for
the rest of the week be with my kids my
kids love coming to Vegas kids sorry
um it's a dream job she's probably
getting paid out the ass like this has
probably been one of the most successful
residencies for uh what hotel was it
about Caesars Caesars and it is the real
Caesars Palace right since Celine Dion
like this is this is huge I mean Celine
Dion's was bigger of course but I can't
imagine one negative thing for anyone
who was involved in this like everyone's
making money everyone's happy so many
videos have come out like Adele goes
viral every week for somebody she does
it's so good for her brand yeah it's
good for her image I don't know why she
would stop and yeah and she said when I
was there she's like I really don't like
touring it's not something I'm
comfortable with like I did it once and
it was hard like it's a lot of time away
from home it's a lot of travel she's not
built for that so to take a 45 minute
flight once a week yeah and it's like
and everybody can come to me and
everybody does come I mean Kim went
everyone goes Vanessa I'm trying to go
yeah like I don't know why she would
ever stop
yeah but I think this is something that
happens with Vegas residencies where I
think it really is so lucrative so easy
um but you get kind of stuck in it you
know I I don't think she's close to
doing that because she's just done 34
shows she's doing 34 more but I feel
like it can be hard to come out of that
cycle because it will get into such a
good Rhythm and as a Performing Artist
who over the years you don't have a lot
of patterns and everything is so up and
down and up and down like you really
cherish the stability of Vegas that's
why it's typically used as like a
retirement plan yeah but I think it's
hard to get out of there yeah
I don't think that Adele will have that
problem though I feel like she's found a
life hack for being a performer
um because she'll still release new
music and people can come and not like
she's going to be there forever but I
think it might be hard to especially
harder to get back on the road after
this yeah because it's just been so easy
yeah
but I'm glad should we do a Vegas
residency kind of I'm down
although when I was on tour I've only in
my life ever canceled I think three
shows and I had to cancel my Vegas show
due to poor performance literally two
weeks out like five tickets had sold
we're not big in Vegas we're not Vegas
it's like a notoriously tough Market
because people don't usually buy tickets
unless it's for like Adele till they get
there they see oh let me see Donnie and
Marie you know yeah yeah so you have to
have a lot of faith in the fact that
people might show up that day and buy
tickets but I was playing a room for a
thousand people and I sold 100 tickets
two weeks out I was not doing that right
and so we have to hope there's like a
thousand toasters in Vegas every single
weekend right right
okay well we'll
we can dream and manifest
um
the other thing I wanted to talk to you
about TV recap was succession last night
I watched succession highly anticipated
season premiere for The Final Season
truly gave us nothing the show you guys
I have to tell you is so bad and if you
think about I've been saying this like
for so long in any given episode
absolutely nothing happens if you think
about how every season has been so
titillating since season one and like
where we started in season one versus
where we are season four episode one
like seriously what's changed they still
up in the company the only thing that's
changed out was there all three children
are beefing with Logan but it's like
they could literally turn him around
stab him in the back each one of them
six times and then like the next day
it's like so are you gonna call the kids
no let them call me it's like nothing is
permanent no betrayal is permanent like
think about what um they've all done not
but Logan but the one Kendall Kendall I
can't ever remember his name think about
all the things that Kendall has done and
yet he's still like has his inheritance
even like right I think Logan likes
playing this game with his kids
um they're kind of only the only worthy
adversaries for him only because they
have his resources at their disposal so
it's just like he gets to spar with
himself
um I mean he is sparring with himself
because they're buying that company with
the money they made from waystar which
is their dad's company they're literally
like the definition of entitled nepo
babies no the definition and I I think
people like who watch the show are Rudy
some people are rooting for the kids and
things like that in the future no not me
whatsoever but like if you listen to
what the kids say like they never say a
word of substance everything they say is
nonsense every idea they have is bad
they really think that they like are
doing something and that they have like
they know what's best for the world and
for culture and like they're literally
so [__] dumb yep and the fact that
Kendall values Pierce at like six seven
billion which is probably worth let's
say 7.5 he was lowballing them let's say
eight even but they paid an extra two
billion dollars to end the conversation
like do you have any concept of one
dollar when Roman was the only one like
trying to break it down for them like oh
we just paid an extra half a billion
just 10 the conversation like what
that's 500 million dollars right like
what that money could be used for other
things so like I don't understand how
after this they have any money left to
their name and really like they have
this opportunity to do whatever they
want with their lives to create the
companies that they wish to see in the
world that they hoped that Logan would
have created all these years and instead
they're gonna take 10 steps back just to
fight and go by again an old ass
basically another version of ATN which
they've hated all these years and they
think is so backwards they're going to
buy that just to [__] with him instead
of like starting something new and light
on their feet with for far less money
and like trying to do something no no
instead like their relics just like the
relics that they make fun of
so this is my first time watching
um succession I feel like maybe last
season I had caught up with like the
last three episodes left so I really
binged it all and watching it in full is
much more exciting because Episode by
episode like really it was boring like I
was bored yeah no every episode there is
like a countdown clock a call has to be
made with the next 24 hours or 48 hours
for a contract to be signed we never
actually get to the signing of anything
nothing actually ever changes or gets
down we just get people negotiating on
the phone and like talking so slowly
with so many filler words like uh yeah
um well so uh like and they literally
put all that stuff into the dialogue
captions and the way that these people
speak in like such broken sentences and
and if you if someone will say a bunch
of words and like when you distill it
down to what they've said they've said
they've said absolutely nothing yes yes
and that's like the vibe of the show
though
right people are just talking to like
hear themselves speak and then of course
last season like Tom big bad Tom like
he's you know
all after all these Seasons like he's
finally having his come up and said like
no he's still the same [__] he always
was because he flopped back again in
this episode and ruined everything
foreign's right to be like if we're good
we're good like you don't get more than
that a hundred percent I just felt like
so bored the whole time yeah I felt
bored except the conversation about Greg
State's purse was quite possibly one of
the funniest things of all time like how
they just judged her immediately because
her purse was a little big yeah but she
was also like walking around taking
pictures and she was out of control she
was out of control but that was
hysterical yeah it was very funny like
little things like that make the show
really funny
um and a lot of like the characters like
quirks but like last night was just so
much like shiv and the kids and I just I
hate them I hate except for Roman and
Roman needs to go back to the other side
but it's like in every episode like
someone will make a final decision we're
betraying that yeah and now it's the
next episode and I'm like well you are
you ready to go back yet like there's no
permanence in anything that happens and
nothing has changed since the first
season like nobody went to jail over the
cruise right stuff like right even
Kendall and remember when he left and he
was just being such a loser with his
like art collection yeah like nothing
now we're back back with the kids with
the kids now they own peers okay I guess
like how do they have any money left
I don't know their finances like I get
that they're like uber Uber Uber Uber
uber wealthy but like it really confuses
me yeah like they're all using all the
money that they got from this Gojo sale
to
buy peers so like well I feel like
something's gonna happen with this Gojo
sale because they keep saying 48 Hours
well I think that Logan should cancel it
so the kids don't have the money to buy
it yes duh but like
but he's like why did he need to sell it
in the first place what was the problem
a while ago because it stunk no and like
in the FBI what happened with them right
no one thing about me is like half the
[__] that goes on in the show in terms
of like business completely goes over my
head like I have really no idea what's
going on at any point yeah but you know
like the big Ideas which is that he's
competing for Pierce with the kids in
this episode but like yes the stuff in
the past I genuinely don't remember why
did Logan have to offload the company so
hastily
right because like they wanted him out
Jose the board member that guy Adrian
Brody Adrian Brody right they wanted him
out and the company also like stinks
like they have like no nothing big they
wanted to buy Gojo but then it was like
actually Gojo could buy us yeah
yeah no I don't remember okay so now if
kojo doesn't buy them okay so what so
we're back to season one episode one
exactly
it's so like nothing ever happens they
were just always on the phone and like
they're always on the phone
it's just so stupid and nobody trusts
anybody else like that one the kids like
don't even trust themselves or their own
instincts at least Logan I constantly
confused Logan and Kendall but at least
Logan trusts himself but like the fact
that those three kids can't trust that
like they're actually gonna be loyal to
one another or they don't even trust the
decisions that they make they don't even
know if what they do is like the right
move they're actually not smart business
people no they've spent three months
like learning investors into the 100
which is just like master class right uh
it's like a startup that's been done a
million times yeah yeah and it's
extremely pretentious and Elite and like
right only for a handful of people right
but they're willing to walk away from
all of that which they thought was a
good idea but they're not sure that it's
a good idea because oh there's this old
dinosaur that's up for sale that our dad
wants right right no it's moronic let's
pull all of our money to [__] with him
like Ben watched the episode with me and
he has no idea what the show's about I
just basically told him like these are
the kids
and that's the dad and I honestly feel
like it probably wasn't even hard for
him to catch up because all the [__]
that's happened in the last four seasons
like doesn't even feel
important no it's not important
right it doesn't feel relevant to this
current storyline and like why am I
supposed to mourn the loss of shiv and
Tom's relationship when like they've
never been in love or had any I went on
Twitter last night to see like if people
were talking about the show and like you
know if I missed anything what's there
even to say what did they say people
were like this scene is so beautiful
like them holding hands being like we
gave it a go such a such a stunning
portrait of a marriage I was like these
people are [__] delusional like this
is not a marriage that's even remotely
relatable in any way it wasn't really
ever real no
um and we're supposed to be mourning it
I felt no emotions no it was beautiful
it was the point it was a beautiful
apartment it's
stunning
uh that's crazy like Tom isn't like a
real person you don't feel empathy for
Tom he's like this caricature yeah and
he has no Scruples he's just looking out
for number one I think when he ties when
he attaches himself to someone else like
if he could just be loyal to the person
that he attaches himself to I thought it
was Kendall but then he like had to go
and call Ship like I would be able you
thought it was Logan
sorry I thought it was Logan but then he
had to go College him I wouldn't be able
to have respect for his at least loyalty
considering like it's not like he's an
ingenue and so in the last episode of
season three when he chose Kendall and
when in Warren Kendall I had respect for
him for like making a choice shift
treats him like [__] wants an open
relationship and like he he's going
straight to the big man but then
literally like that the respect he's
lost and it's so funny how if you
probably look at the tweets from like
season three season finale like Tom's a
man like tell me and now what do you
think you know that's so Tom like I
actually feel like Tom is probably
the most well-developed character like
he's so spineless and he's constantly
being spineless and he's constantly like
exerting the little power he has over
like people underneath him like Greg and
like abusing it he's really this like
insane [__] person yeah but the thing
is I would have thought that his
character developed but then in this
episode that he had to call Shiv and say
the Naomi Pierce
so he hasn't developed at all
no but I'm saying Tom as the character
like is so detailed like yes you know
who he is I yes as a character on a
television show but as a real person no
no none of these people like are really
relatable in any way in the way that
they think like having no Scruples no
loyalty no one they can trust
and like being okay with that yeah and
just being like so miserable in their
lives when it's like why don't you just
go enjoy your life and stop worrying
about [__] with your dad just like
say hey thanks for the billions right
I'm gonna go get on this thing instead
of like constantly festering in this
horrible environment the kids are the
worst except for Roman except for Roman
but he's siding with the worst right now
so he is part of the worst but even when
he chooses Kendall's side sometimes like
he's done in the past like he's not
fully on that side either yeah he's just
always on the fence you mean Logan sorry
Logan it's why is it so confusing
because like the names give it's like
yep yes I know it's like that woman's
Tick Tock where she yeah if you names
that feel the same if you like the name
Logan for your baby but you can't use it
because you know someone else had it try
Kendall by the way they they look the
same like they feel the same they are
the same yeah I don't confuse Kendall
and chips or Kendall and Roman no I know
Roman is Roman they have the same like
phonetic structure there's something
that's a plot hole hundred percent at
the end of the day I stand with Logan
eternally he's the best character I
stand with Logan too and also so many
times he starts saying something and I
was like oh this is the part of the show
where Logan loses his mind he has you
know he's dementia riddled and it's time
for him to retire but then he was
watching ATN at the end
a diner with his bodyguard yep I was
like uh Logan's lost his marbles every
time they like zoom in on him slowly
when he's watching TV and he goes to
call someone and he like literally can't
even move his hand to call he's like and
he starts like babbling sitting I'm like
Logan's lost it and then it comes out
and I say to myself it's like oh Fair
Point facts that guy does look like a
thumb
um I always think I'm like oh this is
how the show ends he's sick
he's gonna die and none of this will
have mattered yeah
like how does the show end
the show is about succession it's about
like the line of succession like does
Logan die does he finally hand over the
keys to someone is it one of the kids
like how does this show end
I think
I think the way it started the kids come
back on board and they're in line
whenever Logan chooses to retire and by
the way the whole issue with the show
the whole reason they're even fighting
is because Logan won't retire because
their dad won't die fast enough right
they're so evil these kids they're so
evil so I think it'll go back to the way
that it was where the kids come over to
Logan's side they also own Pierce now
they have an even bigger Empire and if
you could just [__] wait for your dad
to die instead of kicking it into the
grave it will all be yours
yeah but which kid that was the whole
point oh well that's something they have
to sort who's running Pierce they still
have to figure that out amongst
themselves Kendall Logan is Never Gonna
choose one of them though he should
choose Roman even though Roman is also
disgusting you have to remember I know
who is in a little bit he's done some
really like perverse stuff not even the
Jerry pictures like
um
like with the girl I forget what it was
but he's like he's really degrading and
like he has some clear mental health
issues yes yes but he seems to be the
better person of the three of them yes I
agree and he seems to be the one with
like the slightest bit of family loyalty
yes and who do you dislike more shiv
Kindler ship ship
I I really like Kendall is far and away
like the worst because he's also really
easy to hate but yeah she still has been
so humbled like I know like killing
someone yeah I know it's nice when
somebody's so evil like gets what comes
their way like it makes them more
likable yeah shiv is just like
constantly floating through life like
bulldozing and no consequences no and
she seriously like thinks she's smartly
Superior to everyone she thinks she's
the smartest person like even when she
was opening the door at the Pierce's
house and like coming in with her new
offer when she had the 10 million she
had this [__] smirk on her face I
just wanted to slap it off she was like
10 million billion I like I just I
really don't like her I really don't
like her as well it's like they all got
together and said how can we create the
most unlikable character in the history
of television and shiv Roy was born
the thing is like people who watch this
show like one love it and I think I like
the show a lot I think people like love
shiv that's crazy I think people are
team Kendall over Logan T people are
team kids but even when it was Kendall
vs Logan and the the other two were just
saying the other two were like working
for uh way sort of Graco that's also
weird a lot to say star royco they were
working for the family business and
still like talking to
Kendall
um so it was really a battle like team
Kendall or team Logan like people on
this Earth a lot of people yeah team
Kendall maybe even like the majority of
people yeah
L to the o g
dude be the OG and I'm gonna play yen
so good that was the best part
yeah
dude be the oh gee but it was it was
terrible it was horrifying but somebody
like can't like Kendall would do that
like that level of narcissism like
thinking that's a good idea yeah
but also the thing about Logan is like
even though he's so smart and this and
that it's like he's actually not because
he has nobody worthy to leave his Empire
to right he's surrounded by enemies his
family like so what so
so what's all this for that's a great
point but I think he also fostered this
environment of competitiveness and like
mistrusting of the kids and I think a
part of him also likes it yeah he's
created his own enemies but he he I
think he likes having enemies
yeah well it keeps you on your toes yeah
so hopefully more happens next week
because I was unsatiated
this week nothing's going to happen next
week or anything but then when we watch
the season finale I think we'll be able
to say what happened this season right
right right I think I hope
a girl can dream
um so that's our show nice long one for
you I hope you enjoyed it hope it got
you to lunch maybe even dinner depending
on when you're listening to this
have an amazing day thank you so much
for listening to the toast the
millennial Morning Show where we deliver
the past five stories that you need to
know everybody through Friday on YouTube
so you're watching this on YouTube
please don't forget to subscribe give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available podcast anywhere podcast we
found so it's Spotify
talented we are
I'ma see you tomorrow for Tuesday
Tuesday show bye love you bye